mein gott was für im blick das back mir
immer wieder und diese stille herrlich
[Musik]
klar ist dass apple macht
den lärm aus du musst du ein spiel zu
gewinnen und dann haben glaubt die musik
über die kopfhörer kriegt dass fettes
tutorial rein dass ich mir über die app
aktiviert hat und damit ein bisschen
mehr spaß macht habe ich den peter
hinten dran
solltest du auch mal ausprobieren ein
bisschen mehr cardio bodyshaping und so
meine konturen sind ja schon ein
bisschen soft
sonst einfach haben wir den rand rücken
oder winzig bis du verstehst start-up
relaxt ich alter was für ein geiles
autor viele her
[Musik]
mein puls ist weg dann ist alles klar
du bist tot
das heißt ich muss noch ins tal
[Musik]
jameda in diesem fall schon mal die
erste elf kommt erst mal suchen wir
fertig werden ich kann nicht nur so zu
tun
[Applaus]
und jetzt sexy
alten irgendwie voll fans die augen
stimmt
wenn sie in panic du von uns machen ross
seymore picture in picture wir lehnen
uns über den abgrund tun satz würde mir
abstürzen und osten wieder noch septett
und elfter ist natürlich nur fall der
fake aber mega cool gibt sie eigentlich
wie lan
sowie so
ja klar und wen es wettermäßig um eine
zugabe mit dem wlan direkt hinter dem
felsvorsprung zürcher internetcafé
ja da gibt es ein cappuccino latte
macchiato alles
nagelstudio und einkaufszentrum kommt
auch drauf da wäre aber exakt der ganze
berg dafür abgerissen damit ihr
einrichtung in passagen für einen blöden
selbst nicht mehr extra darauf
dass irgendwie spooky schauen aber
zehnmal ich will davor noch ein
cappuccino trinken gehen ein bisschen
schatten
erfreulich blockiere ich jetzt auf cnet
ist da und auf facebook beide bis heute
übrig gehabt du hast echt eine saudumme
wie salto
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nullo und jetzt alle
[Applaus]
hallo versorgen bis wärme ins fertig ist
hallo mein name ist michael brocken ich
bin jude lehrer und erlebnispädagoge
wir sind hier um den wolligen klang
unserer stimmen im akustischen raum
dieser herrlichen natur zu entdecken aha
und das geht und ein troll nicht sie
sind mir eine
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
rechts jetzt hat schaut das zweiter
grund sie will jetzt endlich meine ruhe
haben verdammt nochmal ab jetzt
grüß gott
mein gott dieser blick dieses bad vilbel
wieder diese stille herrlich
aber sie haben uns einmal ehrlich ist
schon oft auch im riesensaal rein in die
natur hinterlässt
hat er die endlich einmal auf kante
herum chance sie bloss einmal die kühe
an die man an sie können überall hin
straßen das hört sich jetzt auf ich bin
von der alpen dahinter haben wir bauen
hier eine bergerlebnis spielte par
excellence mit konto mit gastronomie mit
mit mit outlet center etc
wann geht's los
forster ist bekommt
immer
aber diesmal nicht so kommt die disco
ihn da die alpen ranch des bowling
center und darum kommt das neue studio
mit dem erlebnis frische und hierauf
gibt fehlt da bei mir ein erlebnis cowes
sports inc
das war der spatenstich fürs kaum
sportzentrum
wie solid
[Applaus]